it is the season of giving what better
gift to give than family time today the
Saint Jude's Ranch for children granted
that holiday wish for a group of
siblings separated in foster care
Candace Charles shows us The Magic of
the annual event
the holidays are almost synonymous with
togetherness and family time but for a
group of children that are in the foster
care system that's often not a guarantee
especially during the holidays but
thanks to Saint Jude's Ranch for
children they're making that holiday
wish come true
events it's a special day for
nine-year-old Bell Lopez Cohen and her
older sister Brianna it's fun to spend
time together and enjoy the ride I love
coming over here because it's really fun
to spend time with my other siblings but
Saturday couldn't come the sisters live
in a foster home together and our
lifelong members of Saint Jude's Ranch
for children's sibling preservation
program they've been coming to the
ranch's annual gift of giving for years
usually with their brothers this year
they'll miss out on spending the
holidays with their two siblings an
unfortunate reality for many children in
foster care so our program is the only
one in southern Nevada that has this
unique programming that once a month we
bring these siblings together so they
can you know really spend that quality
time together Bella and Bree joined more
than 90 foster children at Adventuredome
at Circus Circus on Saturday enjoying
rides games and family photos Christina
Villa is the CEO of the ranch and tells
me this event may be the only time the
children get to spend the holidays
together siblings shop and wrap presents
from one another but the biggest gift I
don't really want anything but her is
each other and it's free holiday
experience for these kiddos it's all
made possible with your help you find
out how to donate for next year's event
to have another special group of
children by going to our website
8newsnow.com for now from the adventure
though I'm Candace Charles ages now Now
The Sibling preservation program
reconnects about 280 children a year
with their siblings